Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
Hold on a second.
No problem.
Sorry, I was in a library.
Oh, were you studying?
Yes, I was.
I'm taking a very important exam soon.
Oh, what kind of exam is it?
It's a national exam.
I want to work in public schools and I need to pass the exam.
Oh, wonderful!
You want to be a teacher?
Since when?
Not too long ago.
Why do you want to be a teacher?
Do you like kids?
Yes, I do.
Besides, my mother is a teacher, too.
I think she inspired me a lot.
You'll make a good teacher.
Thank you for your encouragement.
Besides becoming a teacher, what are you interested in trying?
Actually, I wanted to be a musician, too.
Can you play any musical instruments?
I can play the guitar and the violin.
You are very talented.